As the smoke settles from the brawl between
the X-Men and that big, weird, blue guy, it's
time to look at some of the axed scenes from
X-Men: Apocalypse.
While not all of these scenes would've changed
the course of the film, we're still crossing
our claws that these scratched scenes make
it onto the home versions of the movie.
Hope you brought your ruby quartz sunglasses...there
are some potentially dangerous spoilers ahead.
Cancelling Jubilee's fireworks
If there was ever a chance for Jubilee to
shine, X-Men: Apocalypse was it.
A fan-favorite from the comics and cartoon
for years, we wanted Jubilee to have her big-screen
moment.
Instead, she played the same role she did
in the previous films: just another background
student who doesn't do anything.
Fandango reveals that director Bryan Singer
wanted her to shine and filmed a scene showcasing
her fireworks-like ability.
He said: "We do have a moment where Jubilee
uses her powers and you'll see that on the
DVD.
We wanted more Jubilee."
It's okay Bryan—we all did.
Bedazzled
Another heartbreaking character cut?
The rumored Dazzler cameo.
The blonde pop star mutant was supposedly
going to show up on an album cover the X-kids
find in a record store.
Adding fuel to the fire were rumors that real
life blonde pop-star Taylor Swift dropped
by the set of Apocalypse—seemingly proven
by producer Simon Kinberg's Tweeted photo
of himself, James McAvoy, Sophie Turner, and
the Swift one herself.
Kinberg later admitted that the photo wasn't
from the set, but from backstage at Swift's
Montreal show, and that she wasn't going to
Dazzle audiences after all.
Still, hopefully we'll get that glimpse of
the disco-dancing mutant's album on the DVD
release special features.
Brain freeze
While we're on the subject of the X-teens'
mall trip, there were more Nightcrawler scenes
cut from the film.
For starters, the final cut didn't include
the TV spot showing Kurt Wagner experiencing
brain freeze from some type of smoothie.
According to an interview with Fandango, Bryan
Singer axed yet another scene with Nightcrawler:
"[...] they’re moving through the mall and
Nightcrawler remarks about the other people
that 'they don’t fear us.'
And he thinks the mall is this paradise."
Phoenix-powered first-person-shooter
This picture of Jean Grey holding Scott Summer's
neck and helping him aim his optic blast was
used in the promotional material for X-Men:
Apocalypse, but the scene never actually happened
in the film.
It's a shame the film didn't include it, because
it shows a degree of trust between the two
future lovebirds, especially since Cyclops
was scared—almost ashamed—of his powers
throughout the first half of the film.
Hopefully we'll see it in the Special Features.
Splitting the Summers siblings
When the Xavier institute explodes, Alex Summers,
better known as Havok, dies in the blast.
His brother Cyclops doesn't get to say goodbye,
as Stryker's soldiers stormed the Xavier School
ruins and started abducting students just
minutes after the explosion.
Bryan Singer explained that he removed a heartfelt
farewell scene between the two Summers bros.
He said it slowed things down just a bit too
much: "If you sat in a theater and watched
it with all those scenes back in, it may seem
good, but slow.
And I don't want the audience to feel that."
It could be worse—at least it wasn't like
Cyclops' death in The Last Stand.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
scene you wish they'd kept in the final cut...